une personne qui aurait aimé être là ce
soir une personne qui est très très
proche de l'un d'entre eux cette
personne n'a pas pu être là
c'est quelqu'un vraiment qui a changé la
vie d'une personne autour de la table
à tel point
qu'il appelle à toutes les pubs tv j'ai
vu m'a dit aussi la wii et wii
benjamin c'est votre femme aurore votre
quatrième femme oui c'est horrible voyez
comment c'est bien mais je vois que vous
ne pouvez pas vous passer d'elle même
pendant les pubs ça fait qu'on
maintenant vous êtes mariés ça fait
trois ans toujours aussi amoureux plus
que jamais plus que jamais sachez
comment un message pour vous dans un
instant je sais pas s'il est bon ou
mauvais coup là je n'ai pas vu il
habille toi oui elle nous quitte
regardez déjà benjamin castaldi
il appelle sa femme à toutes les pubs et
juste après elle a un message pour qu'on
regarde
questionne le meilleur envol
batteur et élargit micro soigne on est
en direct demain c'est la saint valentin
et on veut de l'amour ce soir on va vous
en donner aussi de la mort parce qu'on
aura des cadeaux on aura des choses pour
vous mêmes pour le public je vous lis
benji
[Applaudissements]
je sais que ta femme tu ne fais pas un
pas sans elle ouais je n'ouvre pas un
oeil
[Rires]
c'est vrai benji est ce que tu me voir
le message de ta femme
bah oui ce risque avec parme et le prend
aucun risque si ce n'est d'être encore
plus heureux pays à une minute c'est
vrai que l'on dirige il avec fois tout
mais ne soyez pas comme un concept figé
les flûtes oui c'est vrai justement on
va parler de fatou dans un instant hervé
benjamin tu vas voir le message de ta
femme c'est vrai elle l'a annoncé hier
catherine alors ça qu'on n'a pas de
puissance quand même une idée voilà
benjamin ta femme au rang a tenu à te
laisser un message avant la
saint-valentin tu as prévu quelque chose
avec elle pour la saint-valentin demain
il se trouve que jamais des enfants en
vacances demain d'accord et sinon avec
elle ou sa hausse qui met vous tout seul
oui et vous êtes là lundi quand même
pour l'émission c'est bien sûr chef et
que ça qui vous intéressent voix bah oui
on bosse bordel regardez mon amour
je t'aime déjà je serai pas là ce soir
j'aurais adoré être là mais ce soir ça
n'est pas possible en tout cas je
voulais te dire que je t'aime très fort
et que c'est toujours un bonheur de se
réveiller à tes côtés de matin voilà mon
petit soleil donc ta petite à des thèmes
très fort et puis et puis rentre vite
[Applaudissements]
ouais
c'est beau public de merde la musique
c'est beau c'est de ces mots tu es un
garçon très heureux nous lui répondons
benji pas par sms parce qu'on n'a pas -
voilà elle c'est pourquoi je suis très
ému et
ce jour
autour d'une chope
c'est mon bébé ça et j'espère je pleure
dans ses émissions j'espère aimons benji
j'espère et je te jure j'espère que si
parce que celle que vous aviez comme
projet peut-être d'avoir un enfant si un
jour ça se fait j'espère que je situe
pense à moi comme parrain je te dirais
également appelé dire tu penserais plus
simple plus avoue quand même cadeau est
très mignon c'est clair on voyait que
j'ai remis et on disait on parlait de
benjamin et on disait il à ses pleins de
trucs
ahmad awa est malgré tout ce mec est
toujours toujours de bonne humeur c'est
vrai c'est incroyable je vous préviens
je veux dire il est toujours de bonne
humeur soir là et je le dis benjamin
c'est vraiment devenu mon ami le c1
voilà s'il à n'importe quel problème je
suis là les blesse la de boeck de
bagarre jean pas de ouf voilà pas un
petit problème d'argent ben oui quelque
chose est en tout cas mon benji un
bonheur incroyable fusionner mais
s'appelle tout le temps en ce moment on
se moque mais moi je sais fantastique
2.2 et caen va chez eux c'est vraiment
je la vis d'une fois de sa maison du
bonheur nous accueillent jeu simple n
importe quelle heure vous accueille on
boit un verre on rigole et tous ses
romans il est fantastique pour ce
premier jour
et champion est en tout cas vous êtes
très amoureux ça nous fait plaisir c'est
comme isabelle et son mari s'envoient
des pigeons voyageurs
la journée toute la journée toute
l'agencé toute la journée